the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to round
eight of the 2022 fall chess classic my
name is Jonathan schrance and I'm happy
to be joined here with Grandmaster Miro
hello everybody and Mira we are getting
close to the end here it is very likely
that we might even be able to see a
clear winner in the B group at the end
of today a group is I mean technically
there's a theoretical chance we could
but it's exciting it's going to come
down to what happens today and tomorrow
and we got a lot to look forward to is
there anything that has you most excited
today oh well hans's game which for one
some strange the reason we decided like
not to be a focus the main focus of the
day is very exciting so I can't can't
wait to look at it yeah we definitely
have to take a look at some of the
leaders but don't worry there will be
Hans there will definitely be Hans today
but let's get to know what's going on in
the a group with our standings so at in
the a group we do have a clear leader
and it's Yu Yang Yi with 5 points but
right behind him with only uh with only
a half point less at four and a half we
have Von Nguyen who really could uh
potentially catch up to our leader and
there's a handful of people at four we
got vidit Gujarati we got Gregory
opportun and Below him everybody with
three and a half technically has a
mathematical shot of catching up that
includes Hans Neiman Ilya nijnick nijot
amsav and Aram hakobian uh those that
have already been eliminated from
getting first place are Nicholas
theodoro and Surya Ganguly but they can
still play some excellent games for us
in Miro could you please let us know
what's going on in the B group uh in the
big group we almost have the cliche not
the leader but already almost away now
Alex landerman he's guaranteed the tie
for the first in the unlikely case he
loses both games today and tomorrow uh
so six out of seven absolutely
outstanding performance and then a huge
tie for the second between Rana sadwani
Dennis Scott Rich Christopher U Garrity
counter on 50 Brandon Jacobson and
tigran harun
well not such a great tournament but
still fighting he has so much to look
forward to but first let's get to know
our tournaments the tournament format
for today's event is we have two 10
player round Robins we have the a group
and the B group you get 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves after that at move 40
you will receive 30 minutes for the rest
of the game and all throughout there is
a 30 second increments now we only have
one day left of this tournament but Miro
could you let us know about the schedule
it is a little bit different from the
last day yeah right so important note is
about the schedule the round itself
starts two hours earlier so it's 11 A.M
tomorrow our show will start 2PM and
yeah in case of a playoff needed we will
by the way stay on air till the very end
to cover playoffs those who are rooting
for a playoff perhaps a group is where
you're looking for a playoff win yes 5
p.m is the playoff for tomorrow yep so
very important come two hours earlier
tomorrow make sure that you plan ahead
if you want to be able to to watch all
of the exciting action now we have a lot
of exciting action for you but first I
just want to say thanks you guys have
been hanging out with us we're watching
you on Twitch we're watching you on
YouTube all of your lovely comments we
are here reading them all and also if
you want to join us on social media you
can do it with the hashtag fall chess
classic you can watch all of the game's
lives on uschess champs.com and uh also
great news you know you can also if you
do donate during the show all of our
money that we raise whether it's on
YouTube or twitch whether it's bits
donations subscriptions whatever it is
it all goes to an amazing place every 75
dollars raises an entire semester of
school of school programming you get a
chess education uh it's usually about 10
classes of Chess taught in your school
to kids that otherwise might not be able
to get it so thank you to everybody that
has donated so far now with that let's
get into it and let's see uh who is
playing today with our group a pairings
now at the top we have Nicholas theodoro
going up against Von Nguyen Von Nguyen
of course is in second place a half
Point behind Gregory o'parin is going up
against
is going up against Hans Neiman Surya
Ganguly vs nuget absov and our
tournament leader Yu Yang Yi has the
black pieces against Aram Jacobian so
this is a very important game for you
who has the black pieces Half Point
ahead but what is going on in today's
game oh well they've actually played in
the got a very fast pace that's move 34
and almost all the pieces disappeared so
now we are witnessing Rook straight Rook
to B3 was played uh
Jacobian just captures it yeah so I can
guess the move yeah well hopefully for
you young it's a recapture of this Rook
uh King still still takes care of the
pawn if it's trying to run forward and
as far as I understand I mean it has to
be the way for white to draw this
position
but it's black who is trying technically
blood black I mean black it's up a pawn
right and Knight G4 will force one of
those pawns to move yeah well it's
probably a draw Still maybe even like a
fourth draw with some sort of E6 in the
right moment and then yeah black starts
taking pawns white stars yeah well
perhaps E6 just makes a drawn a spot uh
save black captures White Sox is this
one yeah just get rid of all the pawns
and yeah all right so that could very
easily be a draw which would bring you
temporarily a point ahead and we would
have to see what's going on yeah the win
game all right so we will definitely be
looking at this one we also want to take
a quick look at the Hans Neiman game
yeah Hans Neiman game and finally that's
as exciting as that can possibly get
because you can see I mean it's uh well
it's actually bacterial equal I mean
Hans sacrificed the pawn someone in the
opening now he gets it back uh two
Bishops two Bishops uh that um yeah this
set of pieces calls trans problem in the
previous game when he wasn't receiving
end so to speak so now on the two
Bishops yes and now he is the one with
the pair of Bishops uh yeah how did they
get here this actually must have been a
pretty fun opening yep there was that
was uh the so-called svechnikov Sicilian
uh right not
um not such a such a common guest
nowadays even though there is nothing
these are our second one of the
tournament yeah nothing wrong with the
opening per se it's just that yeah
people somehow you know the
uh the fashion changes and much more
often we have Italians the C4 E5 stuff
yeah but yeah the castle C3 all that is
still like Theory having everyone has
played with everybody a lot of cars and
games with black
so up to this point Knight C2 Rook to B8
yeah and Rook B8
black wants to play A5 so A4 not letting
black doing so Knight to B4 Bishop to B7
9 ah sorry a night before Knight takes
before yeah still still we still like in
a familiar territory and even like
Wisconsin games being here Knight takes
before Bishop B7 nothing new Customs
games Customs game disappeared though so
perhaps something something else was
played by Magnus Knight to A6 and Knight
to up sorry Knight takes A6 is a first
yeah Knight takes one our new move take
the ball no take the ball yeah very
logical absolutely preparation yeah
actually yeah well it's a porn yeah so
if anything okay Queen A4 yeah and it
looks a bit kind of unnatural right
self-binning on the a file but it it's
either Aliens new everything yeah well
D5 break in the center let's open
position the position Bishop here Rook
A7 preparing for Rook A8 it's White
Castles
ah okay Rook A3 once again a little bit
awkward but a legit way of protecting
The Rook on the a file D takes E4
castles E3
once again insisting on sacrificing the
pawn and white chose not to not to
capture it so that's uh has just played
E4 yeah okay he's gonna open it up I
have more pawns on the E file yes
that's what you want to do when you got
the Bishops so that's yeah that's
entertaining this is is this is
potentially the best position we've seen
Hans have all tournament wow well one of
the most exciting for sure yeah
definitely okay so we'll definitely have
our eyes on this game as well but
obviously we do have a lot of action in
the B group where we might potentially
Crown a winner as early as today so
let's get to know who is playing who in
the B group
go ahead yeah okay so it's Ronald
sadwani against gergely Contours so
those two are tied for the second place
obviously a very important very
important game uh Chris and Brandon
Jacobson tigran harutiyan faces Arman
mikhailan Christopher you and akshard
Chandra and Dennis cutridge once again
one of those who tied for the first for
the second place is facing a tournament
leader Alex Lenderman Sir Alex I believe
yeah I mean it's obvious by now he only
needs a draw to clinch the tournament
Victory half a point we'll clinch first
place yeah so here as in many many
Alex's games the position is relatively
quiet he finds himself yeah with black
here in uh yeah symmetrical more or less
symmetrical Pawn structure everything's
solid yeah I believe the way Alex likes
it this is yeah especially if you only
need like a draw in your style is I get
a nice solid position like this I think
that's the appropriate way to continue
playing so yeah it looks like it looks I
mean good in the sense that if you only
need a draw this looks like an excellent
position for black yeah and that was
that was yeah I thought it could figure
out what the opening was it was
something yeah white was basically
playing like kinz Indian starting with
Kinsey building up the king's Indian
with the white pieces so some Knight F3
G3 like not fighting for the center all
that much D3 and so on and so on after
E4 he decided to trade and yeah it's a
pretty much playing this position was
the open D file and
not much you can do especially against
Slenderman who is so solid Bishop to A6
fd1 not much was happening I'm afraid
which is good news for if you're an Alex
landerman fan you don't want too too
many complications so traded white
captured on D7 went Knight D2 yeah and
you can you can potentially see how it
all unfolded B5 Bishop B5 then
swapped stuff on the a file 96 Bishop G4
yeah and we are getting there we are
getting the king f8 Rook A2 rookie 2 F6
Rook to D2 Knight C5 and Rook to a one
yep
if anyone it potentially can be black
who is better because the Knight on D6
it looks nice but it's not really
attacking anything black has a more
active Rook we'll see and we've seen
lend them on kind of grinding a win on
move like 60 70 already for a few times
in this tournament so yeah maybe we'll
get to see another one today which I'll
just give him a little bit more time to
maybe soak in all of their Glory
uh Miro is anything else are there any
other games yeah
I mean there's quite a lot absolutely
yeah obviously hans's game is like is
fascinating uh by the way I think it
could be if not the first but one of the
few occasions so once again a reminder
we are starting three hours into the
round right kind of not a single result
yet right it's not a quick draw no one
get got crushed you know in an hour yeah
all the games going so that's hans's
game E4 and yeah just quickly
I guess it's sitting here for just a
second I imagine what if Ilya I'm
assuming he's thinking maybe I keep it
closed yeah yeah so that's that's of
course the biggest kind of the biggest
debate here do you capture E4
which to be perfectly honest I don't see
kind of an immediate refutation but it
does look scary
diagonal yeah I said maybe black just
doesn't really doesn't really care just
takes with the bishop and you know
continues from here uh so F4 is very
tempting yeah F4 is very tempting and
then
what happens by the way
um it could be I mean if anything I'm
kind of tempted to say so now since like
the pawns are that far Advanced I might
have some outposts on like D2 right it's
a rook d8 and hopefully get to D2 but
it's not attacking all that much on D2
the bishop 22 is protected what the
white ones is Knight to C5 or maybe
maybe even like Queen to C5 to cause
some simplifications yeah
I mean I can't help but take this
opportunity but if you can put f4 on the
board here for just a second uh I don't
think I've ever been able to have the
pleasure of asking somebody so strong
this very important philosophical Choice
question uh looking at these e-pawns
okay so black obviously has these two
epon stacked up how many past puns does
black have
um two pounds all the same file because
I know this is something that people
like to debate because there's a pawn in
front of the Pawn on e4 uh yeah but it's
your own Pawn kind of uh yeah yeah well
this is that's a good that's a good
argument there is how many bones yeah so
uh all right so yeah black here
obviously
still here it looks like it's doing very
well whether white takes or pushes or
white continues here uh right I mean we
probably should look for some kind of
cool and called clever move for black
yeah but yeah somehow I believe in his
prospects here
so it could be even like moving the
moving the bishop somewhere so that
whenever white moves we trade on a tree
we are not that unhappy
uh it actually surprises me how so that
Ilya is thinking here because yeah F4
seems to be well
kind of asking for itself if we can sure
if we can paraphrase hans's interviews
yes F4 is asking for itself but yeah
Hans needs to swing the dark Square
Bishop yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking like I say if we ever can get
the bishop to F2 we'd be very happy but
G3 is the move that concerns me and we
are not yet ready to suck on G3 The
Queen Is Not joining right uh would
white have a five-year share we would
consider like taking a green G5 at least
getting somewhere probably doesn't work
anyway but who knows with uh pawns being
where they are yeah so G3 will have to
go back no that that's not something we
do we have something like this for maybe
our Rook that's on f8 whether it's on
the a file yeah yeah so that's that's
yeah that's of course one of the one of
the myths to consider maybe Rook to C8
strangely so that the Knight is not
moving so it's kind of trapping the
night yeah and if not before yeah I'd be
very happy to say trade and then win
back the pawn that black
why am I still on the impression that
block is down a poor because he was he
was yeah yeah so it's winning the porn
for black okay that makes it
um
yeah I mean okay so it looks very
pleasant for black if you can just you
know continue developing your pieces and
get a good position yeah so it's very
promising oh YouTube chat has some
suggestions like go Queen D6 which is
okay uh not that uh not that silly at
all yes I'm queen queen D2 hints also
attacking the Knight
perhaps Knight C5 is what the White
Steel does okay
yeah perhaps you have to be a little bit
careful with this one because Knight C5
Rook A3 white all of a sudden might have
this intimate so the final intermediate
move attacking the queen and the Rook is
still The Rook is still hanging okay you
got to be a little bit careful there
yeah but still it just it does feel
really good for Hans something is you
know not like there's a winning blow or
anything but it feels like the position
might be able to just positionally kind
of improve uh and in the a group we
actually do have a major result
um
the tournament leader
um
alrighty so
I don't think we actually looked at this
one from the start if we just oh yeah
yeah just quickly
all right and this does obviously
officially mean the tournament won't
officially end today for you Yang Yi
people still have the opportunity to
catch up which we'll be able to look at
in a moment
one of these
so right that that's uh because but that
we had in the in lenderman's game
yesterday
so waiting for Knight B to D7 then
captured on D5 Bishop G5 Bishop B4 and
now it's a mixture of probably not even
a mixture it's just a rogos in defense
the bishop is on B4 for blacks that
imagine we played there goes in defense
moves over then white captures on D5
goes Bishop D5 and black replies with
Knight to D7 yeah E3 Bishop to F6
because now since the bishop went to B4
uh you have to be careful in case Bishop
H4 black might and probably should
consider going G5 Knight E4 you know
using the using the PIN
of the bishop takes F6
um
how many captures are there well taking
with the pawn is not that bright yeah
taking with the Knight
seems the most natural but yeah but it's
a check so therefore
therefore I'm actually somewhat
surprised he captured with the queen
even though it leads with the
transposition to something really known
because yeah like they takes on C3
Knight F6 feels much more natural but
yeah all right so Queen takes Queen to
B3 Queen D6 so this way he guards both
the bishop and and the D5 pawn
and perhaps planning to keep the bishop
not to trade it for its C3 Knight yeah
that's exactly what happened to B5 and
now you probably are forced because the
bishop is hanging Bishop B6 would mean
losing your Pawn so
it's kind of funny how Wade spent all
that time to really make sure yeah trade
on C3 yeah uh Bishop D3 C5 C4 okay well
C4 is
it's quite aggressive I have to say
95 B5 and these are these are usually
repositioned black is trying to avoid
well at least that that's what I thought
just with the center closed like this
where I can maybe play E4 in the future
these are the kinds of things to avoid
uh
so here once again I mean you probably
you probably would love to stop this B5
because yeah if you look at the
structure right it's a white potentially
and that's a very common plan can plan
for F34 but for this you need
uh well you need as small pieces as
possible to stay on the board right so
it's it's a breakthrough in the center
with incentives to come up with King
side attack so to speak therefore like
white trading on D7 and then like opting
to play on the
on the queen side perhaps just favors
black so A6 a b a b he wins the pawn in
in a moment he kind of wins The Pawn on
B5 maybe that's what he was this is why
it happened maybe that's what he was
going for but then after G6 yeah that's
kind of not rush winning the pawn back
because yeah looks like a back rank mate
but there is a bishop on C2 chat was
Chad was asking for
helped me well they were actually saying
now that that's terrible when people
show some help help made and I thought
yeah why not uh yeah but G6 turns out
white even has a temper but still easy
not in time yeah not in time to protect
the sea pawns that's what that's
basically what happened Rook C3
F3 and all right yeah looks like Black's
totally fine not G4 yep we saw somewhere
around here like age three perhaps once
again everything's calculated this
Knight would have would have jumped to
E3
E5 yeah that's pretty straightforward
for P3 traded
all right yeah E6 yeah E6 was played DX
Bishop takes takes takes takes
everything
black is a piece up in the final
position there you go all right and so
that with uh for you Yang Yi means he'll
be saying now and five and a half points
so I'm actually curious what's going on
in the Von nguin game Von Nguyen came in
a half Point behind uh you so if he's
able to win somehow he would catch up
and tie for first place so fun yeah fair
enough with the black pieces here oh
that's been some tricky game as I can
tell from it's like it fell from this
Rook being
yeah sort of
sounds
look from the very start maybe it's not
dropped I don't know
yeah this is crazy
wait a second yeah I mean let's just
quickly
started how did the rip get confused in
the starting position so the Catalan and
the one with C5 and Knight C6 and we've
seen this right d takes Queen D1 Rook D1
I think I think like white allowed or
black allowed to capture on d8 in
another game so it was the black king
that ended up on d8 uh yeah but
yeah it's actually kind of and you
pointed out this line you're like oh
here's how they could have done it they
were listening castles yeah Knight B3 or
night yeah yeah I think I mentioned this
Knight beatrio 91 Knight D3 both being
possible Knight to D4 not B 94 yeah
Bishop D7 Knight B5 Knight E5 Bishop to
A3
and this is how white ended up with a
knight on A3 okay
how does The Rook get in there four
years I mean something's happening there
Knight G6 Bishop B7 white captures the
pawn black chose not to interesting yeah
C3 interestingly okay now he does it
E5
white girls after a seven pawn and H5
Rook d8 okay so he wasn't it wasn't in
the mood to protect the the pawn with
Rook A8 which kind of looks ugly right
that's a hard move to play page five
Rook d8 so relies on uh some counter
play against the king yeah and he
actually has quite I mean some material
is still there rook and two knights uh
while white piece is stuck in a you know
the queen side
it's a black
officer draw in a way right
H3 that's a funny movie if you capture
yakim G2 The Rook strap so check king of
one
and that yeah well actually
strangely enough it doesn't really avoid
the draw right because you can still
give a check go to you one and do do
your thing like king of two Rook H1
anyway ah no way to say but then he's
winning a Tempo then and now I figured
this one out because that was the
position when he played H3 right yes and
then with all those repetitions it'd be
yeah the same position with white to
move now good to know so Rook H2 King F1
Knight to E7 Knight is headed to F5 I'm
guessing Knight D4 H 4 Knight F3 check
night King G2 so why not my G1 not my G1
because because he would Pawn takes and
you can't oh wait a second takes King G2
right and qg3 and The Rook would be
trapped
wait a second so check
wasn't it she won a theme
my G1 was a thing for a second
so Knight G1 uh Rook H2 maybe not to let
you play somehow I gotta get my other
Knight to F3
oh okay yeah okay so maybe The Rook is
not trapped
oh it felt like it no but you felt like
it in there it's very close yeah
anyway it could be why it's just yeah
enjoys this one it's a king to G2 Rook
A1 uh once again what's the material
uh born up for wide but like I believe
if you just say take uh take this one
it's Rook A2 and rookie two so you can't
even can't even have the extra Pawn huh
kind of frustrating yeah night takes
through K2 it's not the position you
play for win with white I mean whites
like all over the place right the
knights on H4 this one's pinned on A3 E2
is hanging
so all of a sudden let's threaten our
own things
I presume black ghost G6 then maybe play
Rook to seventh rank try to take F7 once
again material is so limited it feels
like yeah we are heading towards the
draw but still something to play for
all right so yeah we will be keeping an
eye on this because again it is fun to
win with the black pieces here a win
somehow would bring him up to a tie with
you Yang Yi but as it is maybe the
closest possible result here is a draw
in this one which would mean tomorrow
will be a little extra exciting is there
any added pressure on you know a player
in this position you're half Point
behind you know the result of the uh the
you Yang Yi games you know you're one
point behind at this does that change
how black plays at all or do you think
these guys just are playing chess once
again it doesn't matter how much you try
you won't get the direct answer from me
right so I'll be I'll be still awesome
yeah so it'll be depending on the player
depending on the tournament so in this
one it's not like it's a first place
only thing right imagine that to be the
candidates and you're playing for the
first place in order to play the match
right then half of me Point behind so
second place as good as the last one
sure and then you are pushing of course
yeah but here we don't know I mean maybe
he's very happy to be as a second late
to take second place third place to just
finishing plus and therefore like he
will of course play the position which
is in front of him on the board but he
will not over push so that that be
that'd be an explanation but usually
usually yeah like uh you probably do get
the moment you understand I have a
chance to catch up with the leader that
kind of gives you an extra I don't know
motivation booster booster pressure
perhaps all right well all right we'll
see if there's any extra additional
boost of inspiration for Von Nguyen uh
what else has your attention yeah chat
he is asking for operating and video and
that's one that's one
crazy position over there
black queen being stuck well literally
not having a single move so we're gonna
trapped her up to a trapped Queen yeah
that that one is
all right
[Music]
are these pieces getting where they are
yeah that's once again that's a puzzling
like you see it and you think yeah maybe
someone has just said set this up
wrongly that's the line that we had in
Christopher's used game we saw was it
yesterday or a day before yeah and
Christopher went with D6 and I think
I've mentioned that yeah the consensus
is that you play D5 you know 25 moves of
theory and you make a drool I think
they've been listening to you they're
suddenly playing all the theory you've
recommended I guess no no but wait to
say yeah I guess video it is kind of
perfect example if someone knows theory
in this tournament it's with it for sure
okay so E5 Knight to E4 Bishop D3 once
again like following the big names here
it's Geary carwana it's still the the
old guys or should I say old gods there
is a game of Anand versus Crown Nick
from 2013 for example yeah far B has has
played quite a few with both colors in
fact so C5 Knight F3 C takes Knight
takes all that is still yeah still
theoretical Knight to D7 Bishop F4U have
to guard the pawn queen goes to H4 Queen
goes to H5 yes still gear Ricardo
nothing new castles I believe Wesley saw
games must be there and so on and so on
G5 yeah and now white starts doing some
is this stuff yeah it's going off it is
the move it all looks strange if you
don't know the theory yeah that's the
most confusing captures here captures
here and I think yeah that that's the
model white can play literally kind of
every any bit Bishop hanging yeah yeah
that that's the thing uh I don't quite
remember if it's like C4 or something
but they're definitely been examples of
leaving the bishop E6 is one of the
moves yeah okay E6 is one of the moves
Bishop takes e Force well E4 does not
imply that you sacrifice a piece anyway
Bishop B3 Knight takes E5 F3
if you thought we are talking about some
new positions so still
Michelle
they've used like two minutes okay both
everybody knows everything here oh yeah
now we think exactly when I've paid
attention to the time right spent so
they've okay so they both know they knew
what what was happening there and G4
yeah G4 Queen H4 rookie D1 still
not the high profile games but it could
be the traditional kd-1 is
once again nothing to eat simply
right Bishop D7 Knight E2 Knight G3 well
okay it looks like he does the same job
I mean opt for F5 from D4 from G3 but
turns out yeah after Knight F4 Rook D4
Bishop D3 and he eventually gets this
Knight to F5 so that was the the whole
point neither five Queen H3 Queen F2
yeah if you want to take my Rook please
take take back 95 yeah could could be
Bishop E2 F6 F6 is nice I mean just yeah
nothing happens Queen's not trapped
Queen's not trapped F6 King to H1 what's
going on
this is confusing this is yeah this one
is and wait a second five minutes or
rather five moves ago I was saying they
barely spend any time
pay attention to the clock and now
White's on seven minutes seven minutes
and yeah maybe it is down to 20
positions and what move are they on they
get additional time at move 40 what are
they at right now
there it move 28 King H1 is
12 more moves uh yeah let's hope that
operating before he went for this he
kind of has something planned so next
couple of minutes will come easier but
yeah all right wow we'll see what
happens in this one and it could be good
uh for Gregory o'para and if he somehow
got a win he came in with four points uh
he was also a full point behind the
leader but this looks like the kind of
game somebody might win and if it
happens to go uh oparin's way we would
be talking about him tomorrow
potentially trying to catch up with you
Yang Yi so this is one to keep an eye on
uh you mentioned did you mention
something about Hans or is it just in my
mind it might have just been all in my
mind
but uh what's going on this game what's
going on with the Hans game F3 E4 and it
wasn't F4 okay but yeah yeah
interesting Queen takes Bishop F3 just
back to E7
we need to Bishop F3 Rook F3 and Rook to
the eighth so Ali is down to six minutes
only
uh the Knight is still kind of stuck the
E3 Pawn
I like each report I think it's strong
point he's high he's Hans actually
winning I mean that that's I mean a
question I'm reluctant to ask because
it's hard not to see this Knight kind of
Tangled Up
and it's hard not to start thinking we
got something really good for black hair
yeah wow wow wow wow wow it's there
is there a chance Jonathan
is there a chance for Hans interview
today
yeah we haven't had one it's been seven
draws so far uh all seven draws for Hans
but this is it this is the closest we've
ever come so we'll definitely be keeping
our eyes here we also need to keep our
eyes on the leader in the B group so we
can actually maybe take a look at the
lendermen game uh he had a relatively
equal maybe even slightly better
position obviously again he only needs
half a point if he does want to clinch
yeah let's see
let's see is that the one ah it's
actually done oh it's done yeah that's
it that's it we have a winner in the B
group congratulations to Alex Lenderman
uh was there even there was a couple
moves here but it looks like maybe they
just they did but they repeat it yeah so
I think just immediate it might be two a
check into H1 and a check and two H1 and
that was it and with that Alex Lenderman
is the 2022 fall chess classic B group
winner walking away with four thousand
dollars a huge congratulations to Alex
we will obviously try to get an
interview with him as soon as we
possibly can so we can hear his own
thoughts uh and we did we heard him
yesterday he was kind of talking about
like he was just gonna come in and he
felt like very positive about it you
know what I feel like I'm in a good spot
I'm just gonna come in uh I'm gonna play
my own game so we did it congratulations
all right that mixes up things uh for
let's say for the for the fight for the
second third place
held for a draw and still like three
players playing and you can kind of come
in front of cartridge and then there's
one more round to play yeah
what else is going on in the beaker uh
what else is going on in the big group
yeah let's let's just go well one yeah
just follow the list so the next on the
list I have Christian sharella and
Brandon Jacobson that's the position
after 23 moves both down to 10 minutes I
mean it takes place why don't they play
rapid they can spend the time anyway on
the opening moves
it was till some point like a lot of
pieces was still on the board they
barely exchanged anything and that's
because it was the real Lopez all right
with this
a6d6 line sure which is a little bit
different which is nice yeah
known to be get a better for white but
you still have tough time usually have
tough time proving you the queen is
seven rookie one B5
92 Knight A5 and Rook to B8
right
I'm just wondering how does this compare
to
uh you know what's the line where the
bishop gets on the G7 like the real real
regular rui Lopez with the Braya system
sure so Knight goes to B8 D7 so the
Knight would be on D7 yeah yeah
and later on black would play this G6
Bishop to G7 some positions like that
can occur okay but yeah but in our case
black steel has Knight on C6 which is
usually awkward in the in the ruin Lopez
I mean that that's basically most of the
systems they are kind of trying to or
attempting to solve the problem with
this Knight being restricted by the C3
Pawn it's not very much but it's always
something kind of a bit more pleasant
for mine so here they've traded yeah why
white captures on default with the
Knight obviously not to drop the before
Pawn that he takes tanks Rook A4 Queen
to C2 targeting C7 C6 Rook B1 all right
that looks looks much more pleasant for
white if you'd ask me 98 Knight F3 Queen
d8 and E5 so for now the Knight has some
difficulties
uh joining the game
said either you have to trade here and
then you do get some nice squares but
the C Pawn the backward Pawn right
practically has no chance of moving
forward so white will be almost like
half a pawn up in a way right okay
absolutely all right so a nice little
Pleasant edge here for uh Christian
carrilla and we do actually have an
interview with our winner of the B group
it's Alex Lenderman giving us his
thoughts after clinching the B group
okay
I'm here with Grand Master Alexander
Linderman who just drew Dennis cadric's
securing first place and followed the
fall chess classic Group B section Alex
tell me how you're feeling man take me
through your game and really just just
take show me how you did it like it's
this pretty uh obviously a great moment
and uh I feel like you're pretty happy
right now no of course yeah it's always
nice to win a tournament especially with
a round to spare which means that I can
just play the last round
um you know without any pressure you
know still enjoy the game and do my best
but without any pressure
um so yeah I think uh yeah I'm pretty
happy with my form in this tournament
played for the most part pretty good
chess
um so yeah definitely quite happy about
that um in today's game my opponent
um clearly wanted to fight from the very
beginning because he played Knight F3 G3
kind of avoiding a lot of theory and
keeping me at a distance I mean he's
also always playing one E4 but he saw us
playing the Petrov probably didn't want
to go into forcing lines he wanted to
fight so we got an interesting fight I
played Knight D7 with the idea of
playing E5 the main move is D4 but
um
I thought there's a good chance he'll
just play uh
the way he did because he likes these uh
kind of structures with 92 E4 and stuff
like that build a door in reversed
because she plays field door with blacks
so I
kind of expected yeah and then we got
this position where
um I was pretty happy here because uh in
in the structure without the Deep ones
um I've been taught that the most
important squares to control are c4 and
C5 and I control C5 quite nicely so I
didn't think I could be worse
um and I told my Bishop on his Bishop on
G2 is not amazing so I thought you know
I could be a bit better but I'm not sure
if I played it uh the best way so uh
just trying to um
get this setup you know obviously I want
to try to protect E5
and uh yeah and now I want to play B6
Bishop A6
um you know and then put the bishop on
C5
where a Target F2 a little bit I mean
I've I've played the structure many
times on the black side of the French
and some lines so I've I was kind of
familiar with how to play it but but
then he played a pretty strong move and
I thought I expected H3 but somehow I
missed that you can play Bishop page
three
activating the bishop
and uh
yeah so here's a I spent a long time and
it's a very critical moment because I
was calculating for a while B5 which
apparently
is a good move but I couldn't quite make
it work I thought a b
so Bishop takes the problem is Bishop C3
and it felt like
uh couldn't really make the lines work
whether it's A4 or an ib6
uh and I also saw this move
but uh what did I not like here so if
Knight A5
this should be four I think I saw that
but I thought maybe Knight E3 is what I
calculated
and then I thought Bishop E4 Queen E4
Queen E3 I wrote Queen C2 uh Rook D2 and
he has a very good compensation for the
pawn and I cannot take on e4 I thought
because of oh yeah because tonight's
hanging on D7 so but I could play before
Queen E1 and I still can't take the
vulnerable apparently I just go Bishop
B7 and up
better but yeah I couldn't quite
evaluate it so I decided to I mean I did
spend a lot of time here I decided to
play this clumsy movie okay seven it's a
bit weird uh at some point I want to
play B5 but repair maybe with Rook A8 I
just somehow couldn't find uh I mean of
course the ideal B5 is still eventually
go Knight B6 I was also considering
something with 98.96 but if I go to p7 I
thought maybe Knight H4 I didn't really
want to have to play G6 because then he
has this bishop going to a G7 and stuff
it's okay at Rook A7 Bishop C3 and then
I was quite happy with Bishop before
you know just trying to equalize here
um yeah and to be fair I sort of missed
902 but you know it still seems like
it's kind of equalish
uh I mean because
yeah I mean I guess the point is that
it's a trick if CB yeah maybe it's uh
Queen C2 Knight D3 it's kind of
some uncomfortability here
so but yeah I saw I can't play Bishop
takes and I thought I don't shouldn't
have problems with endgame because my
Rook is very active actually I thought
he'll play Queen F3
but I guess I'm okay here too but Queen
C7 and stuff but yeah he played this
um
and here I thought I'm I'm okay I
repositioned the bishop 36.
um here I thought he would play a four
but
he decided to just play here
you know it looks like this position is
around equal
uh
yeah I mean actually maybe if I anyone
could and the last important move is
Roque one because if I play Nothing move
um if he wants to play a four here maybe
get some unbalance but by playing Rook I
want I prevent that
and now he doesn't really have any ideas
to play for a win I don't think because
F4
oh apparently it's kind of playable but
I didn't think it's because of BC then
very bad structure and after this I
thought I get the phone oh he could I
guess he could take out the Kingman a
rook takes here
um
king of three I guess you could sack the
pawn and not be worse but okay it's I
didn't think I should be a word so yeah
I sort of you know wanted to prevent it
apparently he can still sort of play it
but okay he
he thought for a while and he couldn't
find anything better for than uh to
repeat moves and yeah here maybe I could
play Kings if I was in a different
situation
in a regular open term like round one I
could have considered you know like a
neutral move instead of repeating moves
and I mean I'm probably not worse I
could play for a win but on but here of
course yeah basically what happened was
we we just repeated this until move 40
and uh made a draw here so I guess it's
a reasonably good game I kind of kept my
nerves in in attack and was never really
under big danger
well that's obviously great to never
willing to get into danger and six and a
half points even though it doesn't
matter too much tomorrow you're gonna
have white against uh Christian torilla
yeah Christian tarrilla
and spicyboard since the game doesn't
matter as much we'll see ya we'll see I
mean I didn't really think about that
game so much because I had no idea how
I'll do this game like if if I were to
lose today then I probably would have
just tried to make a draw with white but
now of course I'll try to fight and
we'll we'll see I don't know I don't
know yet I haven't really thought about
it too deeply let's see obviously you
too you take a nice relaxer and you have
a great because you deserve it man oh
thank you so much
that is Grand Master Alex Lenderman our
B group winner taking home four thousand
dollars a very nice interview very
humble and he did actually kind of admit
at the end that you know he was able to
keep his nerves intact which is nice
every interview I've heard it seems like
he's just he feels very solid feels like
nothing's really going on but you know
deep down uh he's really happy with the
results and he totally earned it he
played some really excellent chess here
he really hasn't gotten himself in any
trouble never really having a very bad
position not at all uh all right
Jonathan speaking of winners
right chat had it they were complaining
who would ever
break this trick yes
officially ended of course talking about
Hans Naaman it was just it's a win man
it's a beautiful win so once again
coming back to this position and it
turns out yeah we failed it right that
black must be doing well but we didn't
really understand at what scale it is
because apparently computers as F3 is a
big mistake after which black is already
like much better okay and E4 than a54
was yeah
okay so basically this is this is
already like really really bad really
really bad mean minus 2.5 so almost a
piece down with with pretty bad so Queen
back to E2 looks well relatively solid
Bishop F3 and perhaps white has no way
of capturing this guy back Rook takes
Rook to E8 yep we saw right up to this
point and then we didn't know what
happened after here yeah I kind of get
it so the night's like moving the night
means black trades captures on C3 so
Rook A1 is a kind of desperate attempt
maybe to like bring the Rook to F1 or E1
stop the pawn but then yeah Knights
hanging in the air and also it is paint
right Queen to D6
I Rook F5 and while he could still fight
but the position is bad Queen D2 and
white can't keep up all the stuff
protected he won King F1 and resigned
after Rook A6 it's a nice nice Finishing
Touch yeah taking with the queen means e
to E1 black wins taking with the Rook
postponzi 2 but only for one move and
then it's E2 and yeah you don't want to
be
giving away the queen but that means I
can't help it but to show the help mate
pardon me yes
Hans Neiman has won his first game here
in this tournament in round eight and we
will be having an interview with him
just as soon as that is ready so don't
go anywhere more Hans coming soon uh
what else is going on in the a section
Yeah well yeah it's actually I've
actually completely forgotten to bring
up this game which is an exciting game
between Ganguly and abbasov and from the
current position you can tell that that
there was exciting stuff happening one
guy's got a bishop one guy's got a lot
of buttons yeah at some point it was
not exactly the opening but white used
to have like very very far Advanced past
Pawns
so might as well just quickly run
through this game and whenever we are
ready for Hans interview yeah please
please stop me please interrupt me
that's something that not to miss
uh okay sir this Sicilian with Knight C6
Pawn takes and E5 once again was played
on High level uh well what white sorry
what black wants here
is to play
believe it or not to play the swashnikov
of the Knight B5 D6 Bishop F4 E5 okay
but The Bishop's hanging right so yeah
so Bishop will go to G5 and that's the
real kind of real smashing up so you're
basically avoiding the Knight D5 line in
swashnikov oh the one that was played in
the World Championship right and we were
talking about it uh right but everything
comes at the price and in this case the
price is that white can try to play the
that line that we have in the game like
takes E5 Knight D5 Knight E4 so white is
all about getting to those dark squares
F4 Queen B6 once again that's sort of
known
A3 I'm not sure if a tree is actually
the main move I think what what they do
is C4 and then some some weird positions
like this C4 attacking E2
okay but I guess white wanted to avoid
that please yeah white plays A3 and it's
it's still a Move Like an ant plated
Napoleon sheets it's not like it's uh
off something offbeat yeah right
A5 and we find a game between paravian
and caruana
so still caruana
played it with black knight F1 Rook to
F1 all known it turns out all right
still in theory still following yeah
Bishop D2 is the First Independent move
I don't know if it's like well you can
see black has spent two minutes so black
knows what's going on he's well prepared
yeah Queen takes C5
traded when King D3 F5
all right this is where it starts Knight
to D6 take Stakes Rook C8 now the C Paul
uh C4 Pawn is hanging black will be safe
and sound like with the King on F7 if he
gets to capture C4 pawn and Ganguly goes
Rook B5 wow okay A4 Bishop A5 so he
insists yeah they take the rook and
black eventually does Rook C5 Rook to B1
and Bishop to C7 look at this and that
is the position which got me excited
because yeah like the pawns running
forward look at this yeah hard to stop
that beep on Rook a two B7 A3 B8 traded
Rook takes Vegeta
you know oh well oh wow that's funny uh
rugby two is a nice movie and captures
on D6 Rook 38 Rook C6 Rook D6 yeah
doesn't mean we are yes are they just
repeat it now they're repeating
something easy for okay you can see
[ __ ] B3 a check King takes H6 so it's
even material but white decided that he
can play right black pawns are not
running too fast
I presume black should have no
difficulties like trading all the pawns
but that would be a little bit
depressing it's like you'll go D6 E5
basically kind of giving away your pawns
and you expect that black should maybe
try to play for a win uh I think even
without the piece
not to play for a win but like some some
scenario one scenario that I would like
I would like to avoid is playing like
Rook versus rook and Bishop so these
these kind of plays of course they know
how to make this drone how to defend but
once again there should be better option
there must be some something better for
black so not to just you know rush and
try to trade those Pawns
but yeah well if white is careless say I
I can easily see black kind of starting
rolling with this bone mass and then
Anything Can Happen wow all right so
this is obviously going to be a very
great one to keep our eye on the bishop
or the puns we will find out soon oh
yeah what else has your attention why
why else uh back to one win maybe yeah
just to check just to check what's going
on here
he
from what I can see
93 is a threat of a checklist
same with Knight F4 right wait but there
is no G5 check why it's okay that's very
fortunate for why the teeth yes the G5
Knight takes Knight takes King G6
and this Knight goes somewhere
or or maybe H4 you can play so white
will end up being up a pawn as far as I
understand
it's probably
probably still closer to a draw because
very limited material right well this
spawn will be marching at some point
black can even consider sacrificing the
night for it as soon as he can make sure
that H4 is gone as well this one does
have big implications Von win again uh
came into the day a half Point behind
you you Yang Yi has already drawn his
game uh so anything so anything uh here
could be happening now huge announcement
Hans Neiman has won his game we have
finally got him for an interview after
eight long rounds we finally get to hear
from Hans and even himself and let's see
what he has to say about his win today
I'm here with Hans Neiman who is now on
four and a half points and uh upon how
about you just uh completely speaking
through your game and uh sure
so E4 C5 another 396.
we've got a smash the golf
and uh he went for this C3 line
and after Rook B8 he played A4
which is not a great move
um I assume he mixed the lines because
the main line is Bishop G5 A4 and
there's
then then f190 cp4 is theoretical line
but um
or maybe it's Bishop G5 with Rook B8 as
well
yeah I guess it's yeah yeah this is it
yeah that's like 92 Bishop G5 and then
A4 yeah
so he mixed it
and here he started to spiral Knight
before I thought of course he has to
play CB4
but I remember Bishop B7
Rook A4 and I think Queen C8 is very
strong
I couldn't remember the details but um
yeah I could even take and go Queen C7
but then there might be Bishop Basics
Queen C1 Queen D1 Queen B2
anyways it should all be fun
but I think Queen C8 is the best move
but I think after that there are some
Knight F6 and it I think it's it becomes
a draw somehow but I couldn't remember
the details
but he plays night before which is quite
a nice gift
here's what does the computer say yeah
already it's quite bad now wow
yeah he should have played Bishop basics
um and tick tank
and then after Rook B2 there are four
moves to consider those
um scales there's Queenie for the record
for and there's also Knight B4 first
which was which was interesting
um but I missed this yeah I guess I have
Queen A5 if not and then rookie eight
so the point after Castle was to play
um there's also yeah there's Queen A5
and I thought of Rook A4 there was even
like Bishop G5
Castle's Bishop D2 maybe or I'm just
stupid yeah
okay I guess it's better to analyze
without the engine so I look less like
an idiot
um
yeah so he he I don't know I think with
white it's easy to
lose control especially when you don't
realize how bad it is because I
certainly yeah this was a critical
moment yeah D5 and Rook A7
so I was calculating Rook A7 and the
point was after Bishop E2
I thought
Queen B6
but the problem we asked was Queen B4
Queen C6 and queen A4 and it was a
repetition
um
so I was trying to make this work and
okay I guess I suppose it shows Queen A8
cancels Bishop E4
G3 and this is an edge
but I was trying to make it work
um I also considered Queen E7 D4 Bishop
E4
I don't know the two Bishops are strong
but this bee Pawn is also very annoying
myself struggling but eventually I took
quite a bit of time here
um and I realized okay you know I think
D5 is just the most classical way to
approach it just okay the kings in the
center are two moves from developing you
have to be concrete Queen E7 Bishop b2d
I guess I should have maybe taken first
but
take take and E3
so this was I guess the is to find
Knight C5 wow that's that's very
difficult
I guess what I did was find it's just
that um
Knight C5 yeah
because Rook A3 I thought Queen B6 yeah
and then and then rook f8 and then rook
and then B4
wow now D4 is strong I consider D4
wow
oh now Rook A3
oh my God yeah this position is so
ridiculous
anyways
so yeah he has to find Knight C5
oh wait no no the engine just went from
0.3 to 1.7 okay so I guess what I did
was correct if Knight C5 is
okay no no so what I did was correct
then okay E3 because if it takes
the point is that okay Queen B6 but now
I have Bishop A8
um also Bishop E4 might be spite me
stronger but after let's say Bishop E4
um The Rook on A3 is quite awkward and
Rook B7 is coming and then uh E3 is
going to fall and then BT is going to
fall and then everything is just going
to collapse
so I was quite pleased about this E3
move and then he played F3 E4 and uh the
point after F4 is as I play I thought
Bishop takes C3
oh my God I'm just too fancy yeah
okay I guess I I was just that was just
a bit too ambitious okay I thought I was
a genius with Bishop takes C3
but now I see there's Queen B6 but yeah
okay I also Bishop basics
Rook B7 and then Rook B8 yeah oops
and then take on B7 tick tick and then
B2 false C3 Falls you should be lost
but uh it was clear that he had missed
uh he had lost control after F3 and he
also he spent he played it relatively
quickly
um but I think I think this position is
very difficult to play as white because
it's so complex and there's so many
tactics the things you have to be aware
of
so F34 okay
I thought I didn't think he was going to
take enough for anyways but yeah this
bishop takes A6 he told me after the
game
but uh and then I told him Bishop takes
E3 and then he was like oh I missed that
so I guess we're equally both wrong
with the equity for you this is just
over
dictator yeah the Knight on A6 and
working a three the coordination is just
so bad yeah Queen D6 was a nice touch
um
um because the threat is just rookie six
um so he plays Rook at five I go Queen
two two and yeah Rook A6 was quite a
nice move
so Queen takes E2 or fructix
check I've seen and then Queen E3
so okay I was I think a decent game
the only place where maybe I could have
improved was was
uh I don't know
I think I think what I thought what I
played was funny because it's an
extremely complex position it was very
hard to calculate the evaluate at the
same time
um I suppose
but um I think
it was pretty good practical play
and uh obviously tomorrow you're gonna
have uh White against Grandmaster
gargoli how are you feeling about that
matchup
good feeling good just happy to to not
draw a game yeah obviously coming off on
your first win and we hope to see you
back tomorrow thanks Hans thank you
that was Grandmaster Hans Neiman on his
win today over Ilya nijnick he did break
the streak of seven consecutive draws
with that one and it was very insightful
to get all of his analysis of the game
was there anything that stood out to you
Miro uh well once again I mean the moves
like he considered this bishop takes C3
in the book yeah I mean he's brilliant
when it comes to tactics that's that's
for sure absolutely that was a
delightful interview to have and I
believe we also have some more results
in the B group that we need to catch up
on it let's check uh
winning against Michael and the game
that we were barely looked at all it
just means we get to watch the whole
thing it's like a present uh right yeah
so I'm not even sure yet let's run
quickly through it because I believe we
might have an interview with the winner
and then you know just look at the game
once again uh yeah DC44
something not very common I want to say
at least the database already doesn't
know this position all right yeah and we
are getting something like honestly very
symmetrical with white for whatever
reason having a2a4 played I don't think
black isn't at that much of risk Knight
D4 yeah seems fine for black
Bishop takes B2 and this is yeah I'm
taking taking risks
Bishop to E5 still fine though
uh well perhaps not anymore with the
bishopon B8
and black is man back black is getting
crushed now I just realized I mean I'm
switched too fast from like white should
be funny H5 was by the way H5 according
to machine was absolutely terrible
Knight H6 why it's better but still like
not
nowhere near from winning okay and now
basically when we yeah okay captures
this one black is stuck with the respawn
C8 which is not cat it's tough that's a
bishop that gets stuck so often all
right H4 only perhaps adds to Black's
problems because the pawn is now weak
right Bishop C5 Rook F3
Bishops traded Queen F2 and yeah he's
going to take he's going to play Rook H3
and they'll be it right
right
all righty and
all right I think in just a minute we
are going to have a very special treat
we have an in-house guest coming on the
show with us our very own wait a second
I can see it's a result one more result
in the big group Christian has won a
game against visible so we will have
Christian here actually with us on
studio in just a moment yeah I'm curious
to see what was the game yeah that was
that was a nice looking position I
remember
um all right all right so
Christian finally
finally back back to normal back to
winning games
alrighty some more results in the in the
B group for now and two games are still
in progress all right
Hans won a game today do you know
Christian I mean how do you feel I think
we kind of coordinated right he won a
game I won a game
so yeah that was the good day okay so
well done and yes like I can imagine how
tough it was kind of starting this
tournament and it felt like you're but
on me a little bit Rusty like spending
too much time in the opening you know
super Rusty at the beginning obviously I
haven't played chess in like three years
mostly just uh doing commentary actually
in your spot Yeah well yeah I've been
doing a lot of uh this fall and then
spring Classics but yeah it's great to
be back it's great to play some chess
and uh
as the tournament progresses I'm
enjoying more and more yeah
while kind of back on track winning
games and you know well perhaps what's
more important like when you have a good
position you're converting because this
is what perhaps is the most so difficult
it's the most annoying thing right when
you knew that okay this position that
say before the break I would have 100
and then it Slips Away that that's
that's a bad thing yeah yeah all right
so let's let's look at the game quickly
and you'll absolutely just stop me if
you feel like it's a critical moment or
so before uh this break I haven't played
E4 since like I think 2010. so finally I
came back to my first love of uh playing
one E4 and then uh we went to this early
Lopez which I actually looked at today
uh this morning Bishop A4 I think he
played D6 very interesting line tried to
go uh tries to go Bishop D7 first kind
of cut the action of that uh pin and
then potentially the Knight G7 Knight G6
or the way he played it with Knight F6
G6 uh it's a bishop to D7 B4 early like
yeah I think at this point he played
Knight G7 in some games recently and
then Knight G7 Knight G6 this type of
ideas and uh also recently Knight F6 so
I was kind of ready for both of them but
I was really struggling to find castles
G6 what I've noticed that uh here it
seems that you're like almost cheated a
little bit because he'd go Bishop C2
here yeah and so saving a temple right
especially since he went B5 later on
anyway yeah yeah I don't know how it
happened but at some point it looked
like the same position that you would
have in some lines right because you go
B5 Knight A5 and you win Bishop B3
Bishop C2 a year and so B5 you attack
the bishop the bishop goes back yes and
the Knight A5 you attack the bishop
again the bishop has to go to C2 okay so
Bishop to C2 you've got this one yeah
that's one tempo yes H3 castles Bishop
E3 okay so yeah I'm not sure if this was
the move
um I think it was a game by Fabiano
trying to remember against who I think
demchenko they played um in some sort of
a rapid tournament and I think that game
went with Knight H5 or maybe not in this
yeah maybe in this position Knight H5
with the idea to go for F5
um I think Rook to E1 was the move King
h8
Knight D2 and you still have to prepare
the move F5 because right now you cannot
play it I take and you cannot take back
with the Jeep on because I take on E5
yeah the Knight saying is something like
that probably you have to take with the
pawn first and then take yeah
so you have to spend another move to
prepare that rhythm of Queen E8 Queen
yeah 28 and now there's a couple of ways
in which once again when black plays F5
there will be this opposition of a queen
in The Rook so all in all looks like
white is it's a very complicated
position yeah yeah and he went with
Queen E7 rookie one B5 yeah I was
feeling quite good about my position
right now uh it just felt like all of
his moves were in different places like
Queen E7 maybe you want to focus on the
Queens on the king side but then you go
B5 and try yeah let's mix the plans sort
of right yeah yeah so Knight to E5 that
was a bit surprised not that I could
offer a better move for him but yeah
like the whole setup with Queen E7
Knight A5 it was all over the place
exactly yeah
well at least logical and B4 and you
force him back so I think he missed this
move after A4 I think what he was
getting ready to play was C5 and I think
he missed that I can take on B5 he has
to take I take on E5 or C5 then I take
on A5
and then Knight B3 and he just went to
casually win material so you attack this
guy has to say go to A2 this one's taken
with the tempo then you capture the roof
just an extra Pawn yeah yep not much
compensation very symmetrical Pawn
structure so he had to uh play Rook fb8
which is I think a good move
now I was kind of struggling to find
ideas I was like okay it feels like I
gained so many tempies but I still don't
see a clear way typical of this type of
Rookie of this position black is so
solid
so B4 looks logical yeah and now it goes
back
yeah yeah this was a very difficult
moment because I had no idea how to
continue D5 was an option
um D5 Knight d8 I think maybe even
without taking on B5 yeah maybe keep the
pawns here yeah d598 and maybe even A5
right now try to play for C4 and play
for the A6 weakness later on like Bishop
D3 C4 and yeah yeah that's an option as
well that's interesting I've never seen
disturbs being kind of locked at the
queen side yeah yeah but then you have
to worry about C6 ideas and how do you
assess those positions is very unclear
to me yeah but it felt like at least we
we were not digging too deep but it felt
like what you've done was very
reasonable and led to an advantage with
no not much I think here maybe he has to
take on A1 first so this is what I was
worried about take take and take on D4
okay so point being if you take on D4
and now Knight E5 Knight E5 and from C5
exactly everything with Tempo so Bishop
F1 C5 and the game continues
um and I think Queen A7 right now wow
and you still have Queen f8 which
defends yeah and then Queen f8 and these
guys still protected and the Knights
hanging and I had no idea how to assess
this position oh yeah I don't know maybe
we can cheat can we yeah we can cheat a
little bit and okay yeah okay you're
still in control but not much okay yeah
so pretty much with any other in any
other line uh the computer was giving
the same evaluation why it's slightly
better right yeah so Bishop to D3
she takes that's what he has done and
anyway I mean when he ended up with the
Knight on E8 so we need to kind of fast
forward but when he ended up with a
knight on E8 it felt me and Jonathan we
are looking saying yeah okay Christian
with E5 it must be must be something
I'm not sure if even even this one is
not fair but at least from a moral point
of view I have more space and at least
I'm I have some threats right yeah some
jump some squares right Queen A8 he
takes Knight takes 95. there should be
eight yeah I mean who takes on C on E5
that's too much yeah Queen C5 and it
turns out that
yeah
he missed Knight G4
it's very simple he just missed Knight
G4 ah Knight G4 I get all sorts of jobs
if the light is moved maybe even Queen
E5 that's oh wow
check first and then check he can't even
go here so he has to go to G7 then Queen
E5 and you're ready for a double so you
just win immediately turns out yeah
maybe for our Spectators yeah Bishop D6
attacks the queen and any kind of other
discover check is prevented but not the
double check yeah not the double check
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right I could
see it on his face also he he was a bit
he just missed this 194 G4 I think the
best way okay Knight C4 just loses I
think Queen d8 is is the best reply in
this position yeah it's kind of trying
to hold him and I still wasn't sure how
to win this
um is this bishop G5 Bishop is seven
Bishop
the right continuation somehow still
he's he's fighting yeah yeah I was
thinking some H4 but then he plays F6
4 and F6 yep and I was running a little
bit low on time okay we've already
let our advantage gun yeah well Queen d8
you're absolutely right Queen d8 is the
best I'm sorry yeah Queen d8 is the best
move and then if we ask computer
suggests some move that
I personally I'm not sure if I would
have ever I was thinking like rookie one
yeah I was thinking about mysterious
Rook move but it apparently works in
some tactical sequences yeah Bishop G5
is the main traffic yeah
um yeah very complicated still positions
because there's all sorts of like Knight
F5 Knight E4 Knight C4 oh yeah but the
way he played at Knight C4 just falls
apart yeah a check and yeah that's a
beautiful finish six Queen f8 and it
gives me there was one game that okay in
Soviets they kept publishing from book
to book the Petros and queen sacrifice
somewhere it featured the key black king
on G5 and white Bishop
seven so yeah the king is kind of cut
off so here the king is not on G5 but he
also didn't sacrifice the queen yeah
that's what I'm saying Eagle material
right
so it's Improvement on petroleum
sacrifice in a way right uh yeah trade
it I mean somehow I was really trying
not to mess this one up and I think I
found the way yeah
because I was thinking taking on C4
first but if I take this before yeah
yeah and take and now I think F4 was
what I was like 26 26 King F5 King oh
sorry sorry excuse me no uh you go Queen
B8 or queen BH check so that's the
that's now I go F4 so you covered the D6
yeah Bishop G5 Bishop G5 and now it
starts no no no no no Queen E7 and then
I go G4 right but he goes King he's six
wow
and I couldn't still still not clear
right I mean he might Escape here I
don't know
he needs one more move all right so
after a four I do the same thing but I
have the bishop on D3 yeah so I like it
because like you're still winning why to
look for the force line right I mean
just just keep him under control all the
time Queen E4 Bishop C4 now yeah now
Queen E5 wins the queen uh it's a nice
game man it's a nice game thank you
thank you uh thanks thanks for tuning in
and yeah good luck for tomorrow thank
you yep last one against Slenderman for
sure yeah
uh all right so we will be back with
chantan in a couple of moments let me
check if everything is still in progress
in the a tournament apart from those two
games that we already know yet that's
the one of Hans Neiman who has won
against Ilia niznik we know that yuyangi
made a draw uh who are the other kind of
the closest contenders
I'm thinking we did Gujarati against the
point that's the position that these
guys have they've passed the 40 vid it
seems to be winning if you ask me is it
what like two extra pawns opposite
colored Bishops but yeah the king safety
I think I think you like the effect of
opposite colored Bishops is not that
important here
because the Queens are not coming off
the board that easily and that means
this king is in danger yeah what's this
I'm coming back except two puns oh
blacks have two phones
black bean been through a lot of checks
I can tell you
long quite remember where we left it
both of these players were at Four
Points coming in they were a point
behind you Yang Yi so if they can win
they'll catch a half point up and then
be in at least Striking Distance of you
going into the final round yeah
I think it was exactly the moment yeah
like they were almost very low on time
yeah King H1 H5
you know what how to save this queen I
mean just take all the all the squares
yeah hold this guy it's five F4 oh
what's that it's crazy Knight takes
Bishop takes uh Queen takes doesn't
really work Pawn takes
fg5
King G1 so I would guess King H1 a few
moves earlier wasn't the best move
oh
Cafe as long as this Rook been on e4 and
D4 just sitting there yeah obviously
black can never no no one's interested
right so white attempts to go for the
Perpetual with Knight F5 and Knight to
E7 black went with King 8 shade the
interesting is not to H7 because perhaps
some Queen C2 is what disturbs you and
then God knows maybe maybe Queen's
getting somewhere so he went to h8 check
now he goes to G7 forces
so instead of capturing the rule he
insisted on wife yeah Queenie too
and then yeah captured here Knight to D4
sure so now
what's the catch here could
white actually try to take this guy
because you can throw in a check but it
might not do it yeah
then you probably still have to capture
and this if anything is less lost than
the one he has now I mean maybe it's
still lost but
it looks less lost that he has uh yeah
so he comes with CD4 Queen C3 and this
apparently is a is a kind of hard
position to manage right because like
everything's hanging it's what it's two
pawns for black Bishop G5 Queen D4 King
G2 yeah King G6 that's that's what we
have
that's what we have ah CD4 was over here
CD4 was move 40 so perhaps he just made
it like one seconds later he had to make
a real quick move and he got himself
into a little bit of a mess but I don't
know is this holdable I mean it is
obviously color Bishops it's wide open
Kings with the queen on the board
honestly in Practical terms it's almost
like it's almost like impossible to hold
I'm afraid because yeah
uh like uh black is basically two moves
away give a Check and Go D4 and yeah so
perhaps you want to keep the bishop on
H4 so at least if Queen goes away so
there'll be checks on number six right
maybe that's the point but then once
again
a move like that might work so you're
just looking to for the way to open the
bishop and the that that should do the
trick maybe it's not that easy to get
any Perpetual or anything against the
black yeah well white went Bishop F4 but
that means yeah just to check and yeah
well perhaps he I mean he's desperate
enough to go to go forward you know and
maybe even like try to take the pawn on
G4 but it should be winning for black
that that's my that's my opinion anyway
right which would be huge for video
again this video came in with four
points he could get all the way up to
Five Points with the win you Yang Yi
sitting on five and a half so you would
like within striking range absolutely
so what's more Ganguly and the boss of
is still those bones race Bishops first
pawns ah quite impressive so after after
age six white went H4 and I was
I was saying something about how black
has to be careful and so on this is how
black chose to be careful just go G5 get
rid of your Pawn go with four just just
watch forward yeah yeah
so I'm guessing it's not an attempt to
play for a win let's let's be fair it's
uh black
perhaps he calculated some lines and he
tries to make sure that he is getting
halted to this last born remaining so
say Rook A4 and he's going to play King
G6
and if white insists on kind of guarding
the G5 pawn and the very least you can
do is he can play E5 Chuck that guy yeah
which you probably still will have to
defense
that's probably what he's planning to do
since he went G5 because that's a
critical moment right I mean you could
try to play it kind of slower
but then perhaps you're running risk of
not being able to trade all the pawns
and why it keeps one pole alive then
perhaps he just wins the bishop is too
powerful
so therefore yeah this G5
once again not the move I'd be a big fan
of but perhaps it does make a drawing
that that's what's that's what's
important all right so we'll be coming
back to this one kind of still an
interesting imbalance right in one win
against theodoro I keep yeah one wins
not winning this one okay that that's
let's agree on this one there was this
funny game with you know Rook being
trapped and later on like threatening a
checkmate
Knight C3 instead of giving a check yeah
fair enough okay so but it might lead to
the same right of the king takes G3 I
don't think you take it too
oh sorry I don't think you take A2 I
think it's better to capture the E2 guy
go back but who knows so still but
what's important for a tournament leader
for you Yang Yi is the one win is not
winning and Union kind of goes into the
last round right so Imagining the game
is in a draw for say then you would have
a half point lead and it would be kind
of on him he'd have the opportunity to
win the tournament outright tomorrow
all right and back to the B tournament
yes right B tournament where we still
have two games in progress Christopher
Ryu against China Chandra that's once
again the game went a lot of stuff
happened
and you once again you can tell I mean
it was a crazy game
most Christopher U games end up being
crazy games yeah
so
um
yeah okay
I don't know what we do let's let's just
quickly once again check it from the
very beginning absolutely uh Christopher
came up with yeah this bishop performer
oh yeah there's some sort of Gambit here
now
Knight D2 C5 E3
D5 D takes ah okay that's the one
94 Knight C6 a black part was his uh
dark Square Bishop but wins kind of a
few Tempe
E5 Bishop girls D4 well that's
impressive in fact because I used to get
similar Rich structures from one sharp
line in the nimsa Indian but it's
nowhere near as good so this looks like
brilliant for for black there you go
like the three D takes Pawn takes Queen
to E7 Rook D1 A5 intended to play Knight
B4
and white went with Rook D6
F6 calmly defending
defending the pawn Knight D2
so why Rook D6 people may ask because
well he perhaps considers that if he
loses the C5 Pawn say to Knight takes E5
black is just positionally better for
say no compensation whatsoever F6 will
cut off those two pieces right very good
structure a lot of say squares for the
Knight so white is it's what it's moved
like 14 and White's already trying to
complicate the game in order not to be
clearly worse yeah interesting idea yeah
to Rook to D6 Knight D2
black decided to capture I believe
somewhere around this point black should
be doing more than fine
but yeah it's Christopher you we are
talking about how to make this
complicated
castles castles check on B3 Knight to C4
okay Knight A6 back Queen B5 yeah I
remember his game against Slenderman
when he had a chain of Pawns like like
this right so the poll on D6 is
something that he really enjoys having
right Knight E5 wow there you go okay
Queen A2 wow this is where it starts
here we go this is where it starts going
to be six Queen D5 still I don't quite
understand how E4 yeah just add more
stuff it's a 24 Queen E6 then discovered
check on F7 white wins but rugby
intermediate move ever heard of yeah he
takes Queen takes Knight C4 rook's
almost trapped yeah Rook C1 yeah I mean
that's a that's a brilliant game that's
a brilliant game oh there's another
Knight B6 yeah if you take white takes
and nothing can stop Bishop C7 wow yes
and 90 said that that's a game of the
round pardon me I will always all
respect to Hans you know Rook C7 yeah
that's how white got into this uh two
pieces versus Rook Bishop D6 but still
it's not over right because now black
also has a passport on his own
and yeah might be sick they got that
beautiful that's a lovely setup like you
don't want to be playing D6 right
because it lets black to put his Pawn so
Knight to B6 A3 Bishop A3 now black has
two Rooks on the second ring uh almost
like making a Droid be a Perpetual right
but King H3
now I'm not sure what the king would
would it really run to him of course yes
you're going to keep checking me of
course right it's a rookie two Rook to
C3 guards the third rank H5
so now whenever you leave the third rank
it's a Checkmate oh gosh that was never
stops yeah D6 and that's what that's
move 42. so the Bond's almost there it's
77 here Bishop C5 okay that that's the
one that's the position
and so take a guess that's what's the
what's the evolution what do you think
that's why it win I guess so yeah deep
on I mean The Bishop's gonna go back
somewhere The Rook is going to go all
the way up to the end yeah like on the
other hand if black say was to double
behind the D pawn and just take it then
we are not kind of don't have enough
material Left Right Rook take V6 yeah
exactly twitch chat has it yeah of
course yeah you don't even need to
double yeah I mean take B6 take D7 how
can like yeah yeah perhaps but anyway
stuff it's a wild wild game yeah somehow
just looking at it it optically felt
like maybe white is just gonna lose all
these pawns and just get destroyed
immediately but you hang on with all
these kind of weird funny texts yeah
it's not even yeah not even clearing how
the game ends and ronak santwani against
gergely Contour I also have a wild game
which currently is in in this position
I'm trying to trying to process what's
going on the B Pawn is it's actually
relatively dangerous right
so white perhaps will run with the King
to stop the bee Pawn from say promoting
again something really really complex uh
the you know the clock says why it's
down to one minute which to be perfectly
honest I do not believe in because it's
move 43 I think no one flagged no one
flagged there so they'll be getting some
extra time here and he just did he just
did awesome yes half an hour and
probably another half an hour will be
added to Black's clock as well or not
maybe it could be that black already has
spent 15 minutes after time yeah Edition
I hate to wrap everything up but this is
a 90 minute show we had quite a lot of
action all taking place yeah three
minutes
only one day left and it is at a
different time and we're gonna get into
all of that but before we do let's give
another big congratulations to Alex
Slenderman he is oh yeah I think he's
the winner the winner look at that so
congrats again uh to Alex Linderman and
let's go ahead and take a look at the
overall Group B standings uh we can see
here Alex lunderman has clinched with
six and a half points now there's only
one day to go so nobody will be able to
catch but there's a huge he huge fight
for second place like literally all the
players yeah I just realized that it's
not one of those who were tied for the
second but now it's haruting who is at
second place with coverage and still
three games on going no look at all
these games pending everybody is trying
to play for second place in the group b
section and uh in the a group let's go
ahead and take a look at what is going
on this is where we're gonna have a
tiebreak I'm afraid right it's a five
and a half for you Yang Yi four and a
half on Hans name enough to today's win
so still one full point behind well
perhaps only can dream of catching up
with you and the one win on the same
four and a half but his game is still
ongoing uh very likely a draw he might
be on five with it if he wins is on five
as well so two players will be training
half a point it's still a lot of
intrigue in this last round tons of
stuff to look forward to in this last
round and in the event that there is a
playoff we do have some very particular
regulations they would start with a
two-game rapid match it would be game in
10 minutes with a two second delay delay
that's how they all get tricked uh and
in the event that there is a draw after
that it would go to an Armageddon game
where white would be getting five
minutes black would be getting four
minutes but also odds so that is what uh
potentially we will be on to tomorrow if
we do happen to have a playoff and it's
it's very possible in the a group then
we will be staying on the air all the
way until everything is over and uh do
remember that it starts two hours
earlier tomorrow make sure you're here
it'll be at uh 2 p.m central time but
whenever you guys were started watching
today it'll be two hours earlier than
that make sure you're here tomorrow and
we cannot wait to bring you even more
exciting action yeah see you tomorrow
guys it was it was a lovely day it was a
great day
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited